[Musica]
Mi piace leggere mi piace scrivere e
sono sempre stata molto molto curiosa
credo siano questi gli ingredienti che
mi hanno portato nel 2006 a fondare una
cooperativa che si occupa di
comunicazione
amo il mio lavoro
vi starete chiedendo cosa c'entra tutto
questo con l'incondizionato amore per
l'essere umano ve lo spiego grazie a
questo lavoro e alla mia passione per la
cooperazione ho avuto la grande fortuna
in questi anni di fare dei viaggi
meravigliosi di scoprire storie d'amore
storie di persone che hanno messo al
centro dal loro passione per il loro
lavoro per la loro comunità e per i beni
comuni
quindi oggi capite non potevano
raccontarvi queste storie avrei potuto
raccontarvi storie di persone che hanno
messo al centro lo sport lo spettacolo
ma oggi ho scelto i beni culturali
perché Vedete un bene culturale e un
bene comune per eccellenza ora vi devo
chiedere un piccolo favore chiudete gli
occhi e proviamo ad immaginare insieme
un bene culturale che in questi anni ci
ha fatto stare bene di un piccolo comune
di una grande città un museo un'opera
d'arte
ci siete Beh sicuramente qualche sorriso
Ecco ora Aprite gli occhi perché una
cosa da dirvi il 60% del patrimonio
culturale diffuso nel nostro paese prima
della pandemia era o non utilizzato o
sottoutilizzato beni culturali beni
comuni chiusi
cominciamo a capire che questo è un
problema perché un bene comune chiuso
non messo a disposizione di tutti noi È
un'opportunità persa è un impoverimento
però Vedete se questi sono i numeri
dobbiamo anche farci delle domande
qualche cosa nei modelli che stiamo
portando avanti non funziona Ecco se la
logica del massimo profitto nel breve
tempo e quella che caratterizza anche la
valorizzazione di un bene comune è
Allora forse non ci siamo ma se invece
la logica è il profitto messo al
servizio
del Lavoro dello sviluppo sostenibile
del ben essere delle comunità allora sì
che ci siamo e le porte di questi beni
comuni si aprono e allora torno alle mie
storie d'amore oggi vi racconterò le
storie di chi ha messo al centro la sua
competenza la sua professionalità Sì
perché stiamo parlando di persone molto
preparate Ecco la messa al centro per
portare avanti dei progetti di
valorizzazione di beni culturali
E ho deciso allora che la cosa migliore
fosse portarvi in viaggio con me siete
pronti partiamo
la prima tappa ci porta a Prato il
complesso monumentale di San Domenico
quando ci sono stata ma è stato
meraviglioso immergersi In un'altra
epoca circondati da storie di persone
personaggi che li avevano vissuto una
parte della loro vita oggi il complesso
monumentale Ha riaperto le proprie porte
a disposizione della comunità Ci sono
eventi iniziative concerti mostre c'è
anche un museo e questo grazie alla
passione di queste persone Daniele
Viviana Gabriele e i soci della
Cooperativa pratocultura lo vedete dai
loro sorrisi esprimono la loro passione
Ecco non è facile non tutto va sempre
nella giusta direzione però io credo che
abbiano fatto i primi passi nella giusta
direzione nella valorizzazione Insieme a
tutta la comunità del complesso
monumentale Ecco A proposito di passi vi
porto da Prato in Sicilia
qui vorrei parlarvi di Susanna Viviana e
dell'impresa sociale Corai stanno
facendo molto potrei raccontarvi tante
storie ma credo che un progetto che
stanno seguendo possa insegnarci qualche
cosa si tratta del Cammino di Santa
Rosalia Beh Mi direte un cammino Non è
una grande novità in Italia ma loro
stanno provando a mettere tutti intorno
a un tavolo per discutere di quale
opportunità può creare il cammino comuni
associazioni singoli cittadini enti
altre imprese Eh sì anche qui non è
facile perché mettere tutti insieme ogni
tanto fare sintesi riuscire a trovare la
giusta sintesi e la giusta direzione
comune però immaginate Quale forza e
quale potenza riesce ad esprimere tutto
questo quando insieme si trovano a
direzione comune quando tutti si sentono
protagonisti ecco quando ci sono stata
oltre lo ammetto ad un po' di fatica a
fare il cammino ho scoperto anche delle
cose inaspettate
Qui siamo a Corleone il cammino di Santa
Rosalia passa da Corleone e qui ho
conosciuto Rosanna Leoluca e i soci
della Cooperativa ansitu stanno
valorizzando il patrimonio culturale
della loro città anche qui non è facile
ma stanno andando nella giusta direzione
e grazie alla loro passione e competenza
so che arriveranno lontano prendendosi
per mano la loro comunità e poi passiamo
a Lecce qui Vi voglio parlare di Paolo e
dei soci della Cooperativa artwork
quando sono stata da loro quello che più
mi ha colpito È stata la generatività
che hanno saputo avere in un periodo
storico complicatissimo in piena
pandemia i beni culturali erano chiusi
era facile farsi prendere dalla paura
dallo smarrimento dalla paura di non
farcela ancora più difficile era pensare
al futuro e loro invece sono stati
generativi oggi chi valece può vedere la
città dall'alto Grazie un ascensore che
è stato collocato nel campanile Oh può
godersi la storia della città seduti
comodamente davanti al muro del chiostro
di Lecce grazie a un video mapping sono
stati generativi hanno guardato avanti e
oggi Grazie a loro decine di persone
lavorano a Lecce anche qui non tutte
perfetto e non tutto è facile ma la
direzione insieme è quella giusta e poi
da Lecce voglio salire in Friuli Venezia
Giulia qui troviamo Francesco e i soci
della Cooperativa Punto Zero si sono
inventati Pensate un po' il micro
festival il festival più piccolo del
mondo Mi direte che serve un po' di
pazzia per tutto questo sì ci piace
essere un po' folli però grazie a questa
idea in questi anni con questa Vespa
scenografica questa ape scenografica
hanno portato in giro nei piccoli comuni
e nelle piccole comunità
artisti arte cultura hanno generato
hanno saputo seminare
e da Udine ci spostiamo a Torino qui
Avrei potuto parlarvi di tantissimi
progetti e progetti che ci parlano di
rigenerazione base culturale di teatro
di strada ma voglio soffermarmi per un
attimo sui libri Qui abbiamo Fabio Della
Casa Editrice cooperativa Miraggio ogni
anno Fabio trasforma la sua vespa in una
libreria ambulante e porta in giro i
suoi libri e quelli di altre case
editrici per tutto il paese Ecco semina
riesce a essere generativo e viene
accolto sempre con un grande sorriso e
anche con un po' di meraviglia e adesso
vi porto ancora in provincia di Cuneo
Qui abbiamo Mattia insieme ai soci ai
suoi amici nel 2006 si sono chiesti Ma
perché il mio lavoro la mia passione la
musica non può diventare qualche cosa di
più per le mie comunità
E allora è nata la fabbrica dei suoni
che non è soltanto una cooperativa ma è
anche un luogo che io trovo
straordinario Non tanto per
l'allestimenti che sono molto belli ma
per quello che ha saputo generare in
questi anni migliaia di bambini e
ragazzi che grazie a loro hanno scoperto
la musica e i suoni e poi non si sono
fermati a Boves è nato l'atlante dei
suoni un viaggio attraverso i continenti
a base di musica è molto divertente e
oggi una nuova sfida insieme ad altre
comunità Adesso stanno progettando con
Costigliole di Saluzzo e Rossana uno
sviluppo a base culturale partendo da un
bene culturale che certamente da
ristrutturare ma non è solo questa la
logica la logica quella di unirsi tutti
insieme comuni cittadini associazioni e
imprese e ragionare partendo da un bene
comune di sviluppo sostenibile di
benessere per le comunità capite Quante
diversa la logica bene
Io potrei continuare questo viaggio a
lungo portandovi su e giù per l'Italia
raccontandovi molte altre storie d'amore
e di valorizzazione dei beni comuni ma
lascio a voi la curiosità è il compito
di scoprire dove tutto questo Oggi sta
già avvenendo è spesso sono storie
silenziose non fanno rumore ma sono
storie di grande amore per il proprio
lavoro e per la propria comunità
questi amici come me in più hanno scelto
la forma di impresa cooperativa perché
siamo convinti che anche nel lavoro di
tutti i giorni fare comunità essere
insieme fare squadra sia un grande
valore aggiunto soprattutto nei momenti
più difficili quando insieme si va più
lontano ma queste storie ci hanno
raccontato soprattutto che l'amore che
rende generativi quell'essere generativi
che può trasformare le nostre comunità e
renderle luoghi dove vivere vite piene
abbiamo bisogno di questi buoni esempi
abbiamo bisogno di questo sguardo al
futuro abbiamo bisogno di capire che
qualcuno sta già provando ad andare in
questa direzione e allora io vi voglio
salutare con una domanda mi sarete
dicendo che non è tanto gentile e
salutarsi con una domanda Ma io credo
possa indicarci una direzione per il
futuro
quanto siamo disposti tutti noi a
modificare una piccola parte della
nostra vita per tendere a una società
che sia davvero basata che abbia come
senza profonda
l'incondizionato amore per l'essere
umano Io credo che se sapremo portarci
questa domanda ogni giorno insieme a noi
Ecco forse le risposte giuste le
troveremo man mano
ricordandoci di pensarci sempre come
umanità come insieme
e quando avremo paura e penseremo di non
riuscire ad andare avanti a essere
generativi sarà lì che invece dovremmo
ricordarci che siamo insieme e che sono
insieme potremmo essere il vero
cambiamento di cui abbiamo bisogno e
Allora proviamoci tutti insieme
Grazie
[Applauso]